ah non mais une journée de dingue
entre les départs en vacances et
l'absence de rosalie mais j'ai pas
arrêté de courir et serge cerc l enclume
suis là et il est sympa l'accord tout ça
mais alors professionnellement poids ses
limites
avant tu prouves indépendant des foires
il s'est carrément planté dans les
calculs j'ai dû tout refaire dix minutes
avant le début de la réunion
non mais tu imagines un peu mon à
l'époque j'étais là non mais ça va pas
nous y fait et ça va pas qu'est ce que
c'est
oui oui le boss je pense que l'on menait
pas large mais qui sait qu'à sauver le
coup c'est billy brouillard l'eau l'eau
et le lait ça qu'on a dit c'est fait
qu'ils aient tous les yaourts
voilà
oui
mais yahoo sous quai à wind ont alors
quand j'ai pas fini la réunion tout se
passe super bien
et là il ya exposé bigot ensuite ils ont
tout vérifié rien mais c'était extra
c'était incroyable donc est ce que vous
faites un clic droit ça vraiment comment
ça on mange des bonbons mais ouvre pas
les trucs comme ça l'arrivée son père
mais non bah oui oui les gars parce que
c'est mon joueur alors nous vous
regardez c'est trop lourd ou là c'est
trop cool avec le là je sais plus quoi
faire rire mais ma chérie ma chérie pour
fait un coup comme ça je t'invite au
restaurant rien que tous les deux en
amoureux
d'accord et puis les donne à laon les
attaches en elle
on dire
monsieur voudra gonthier voudra puisque
non mais je m'appelle plus avec nous ça
j'étais petit tour machete
215 euros maximum
est ce que je peux vous payer une partie
encartés puis à le parti unique
madame c'est bon pas passé la soirée
ça va je sais ce que je peux bon bref ça
arrive à à m'échapper mais en pleine
heure de pointe mois des embouteillages
non mais un enfer pouvoir un non ferme
et tout ce que je voulais pas alors
heureusement que j'étais en moto j'ai
salomé tu vois comme ça en battre les
bagnoles et j'ai pu m'extirper assez
rapidement on va 2 je voulais faire la
surprise de membres en amérique ton
frère alors là je met les gaz et je fais
le direct à la maison là on arrive en
route de loches en place et ça s'est
dégagé c'est tranquille j'accélère
[__] ya le type 4 4 qui arrive le mec
qui met sont géniaux temps au dernier
moment
tu vois j'ai pas vu moi ja ça va
complètement surpris j'ai rien pu faire
mais je vais taper
à chaque fois stocking sport
cisco
1 j'étais encore trop belle place
oui
on ira
monsieur voudra contiendra est lancée
mais ce sera pareil à un jeu
des indiens
nana na na na
on dira monsieur voudra conti